[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler-free
review of jurassic world dominion so
this is a film where my expectations
were
very in the middle because i was excited
they were bringing the old characters
back from the original trilogy and i
really dug the first jurassic world but
where my worries came in was how much i
did not like fallen kingdom and it's
weird because jurassic world fallen
kingdom starts pretty good and then i
felt like it had one of the worst second
halfs in a movie ever with that crazy
plot twist
of the child's clone and
what really was bizarre to me about this
film dominion is that it rolls right off
of that we get more child clone plots
and things that are just bizarre that
don't land and are silly and
being in a critic screening with that
you had a lot of like-minded people
because when those moments would happen
you just had laughs that shouldn't have
been there that people were just
laughing how silly it was it gets to
that level and
what doesn't make sense to you about
this film when you see it is that they
added all these cheesy villains in it
and it's like whose idea was it to just
you know what this needs cheesy villains
like no one was looking for that
it is so bizarre and it is literally i
hate saying stuff with this but this
actor campbell scott i've never seen him
before but he plays the main villain
here he puts in one of the worst
performances i've seen the screen it was
so bizarre when you watch it you'll see
what i mean but
there's certain lines he's improvising
in that don't work and it almost seems
like he's like
scaring his cast members like where
they're like what the hell like it feels
real in a bad way like
it's so awkward and just makes you laugh
the whole time i mean
like the second half of phone came that
made me laugh this movie has so much of
that and there's people just appearing
out of nowhere
if you really try to even use your brain
for a second in this film
it's gonna sting so
you have to be careful and i get it that
jurassic park movies people don't want
to use their brains that's what most say
right they just want to see dinosaurs
now i disagree with that because
look at the standard the first one made
jurassic park is a masterpiece and it
has such a good script and its focus is
still on the characters now the problem
i've had in general with this drastic
world series is that i still don't know
a thing about chris pratt's character
and honestly chris pratt's acting just
doesn't add anything in this
franchise and really it kind of just
plays off everyone here where
i would say with the actors in this film
with this big cast bryce dallas howard
and laura dern bring it per usual
they're great but then jeff goldblum
amazing right jeff goldblum is the best
part of this film his funniness that
comes in later is great like he always
delivers but
sam neil does not want to be there this
is a film where you're watching someone
who didn't believe in this movie he
knows he's getting a check he knows he
has to be there so everyone else comes
back doesn't want to be there and chris
pratt adds nothing here and
there's other cast members that feel
awkward like some of the new members
that just don't feel like they fit in
um they seem like they're awkward on
screen now i see a lot of praise for
dewanda wise's performance i think she's
a great actress but i don't think her
character is that interesting at all i
don't think again we learn anything
about these people they're just paper
thin and
it's just a bizarre
film and it also in the nostalgia factor
is missing people that should have been
there it's missing anything that makes
you really feel it's very forced
nostalgia this isn't nostalgia that
lands so it's not even like they're
giving you the good stuff with nostalgia
it's really bad nostalgia it just
doesn't work like there's a certain
scene you see in the beginning you
actually actually see it in the trailer
where laura dern pulls her glasses off
she does same way in the first film and
it's just in the most bizarre moment and
some of the editing too where they put
certain scenes don't seem lined up right
like wait why is this scene after this
scene you'll notice those things
especially with laura dern's
introduction which was bizarre to me and
it's also weird that they make a
decision there's more time spent with
bugs in this movie than dinosaurs you
get these locusts that are big plot
point which is just
not good
and honestly i think the most
disappointing part was
it took the route of joining this isn't
really a spoiler but
these groups as we see in the trailer
will come together so it's not a spoiler
but
they take forever to get together and so
we don't even really get to see
the new cast play with the old cast much
at all which is also frustrating and you
have characters we barely know that are
new that save the day and every scene
it's not the characters we want to see
save the day which can get annoying and
it's not all bad i mean it's the
director of the jurassic world the first
one which i liked more than the second
one a lot more
so there's some really good action
sequences in it there was one that got a
lot of claps in the middle you'll see
what takes place in the desert town
which is really good
i think that
there's a lot of dinosaurs even there's
a lot of bugs you still get a lot of
dinosaurs so
it feels just like any other not great
godzilla movie that have been coming out
of late like it's like a godzilla versus
kong kind of thing where you see
ginormous monsters fight each other and
it came to the point of sitting there
watching a movie you look at everybody
with you and you're like you know i i
feel like i'm just watching a video game
with a bunch of people just
giant monsters fighting but there's no
stakes in it you know there's no weight
to the characters in it you can do that
but you have to add some kind of stakes
to our people here because then we're
just watching cgi things fight so it's
frustrating but because of the strength
of jeff goldblum i'm serious he's so
good in this and some really good action
here and there it's not all bad and it's
better than fallen kingdom because fawn
kingdom again
that second half was just deplorable to
me where it was just annoying that this
one they brought a lot of that story
into this and also it's bizarre because
it ends on the hook where the dinosaurs
are going you know into the world but
he doesn't feel like that in this movie
it doesn't feel like a world of
dinosaurs it just feels like another
drastic world movie we've already seen
in its plot and that
there really is no much story here and
also
that i believe with the whole jurassic
franchise the best ones are when they're
in the park i think we're missing that
second half of jurassic world if it's
not jurassic park it's just jurassic i
don't like it that's kind of been my
thing with the films in the past i love
the first one and i really dug the first
one to jurassic world but they both
happen to be in a park when you take
that away it just becomes dinosaurs
wherever it really loses its just edge i
feel too and it's sad it's just not a
great conclusion where you got a lot of
franchises that are doing this to death
with nostalgia bringing back old casts
but they at least you know even
ghostbusters had its really good moments
this doesn't have it here
it doesn't feel it you don't feel that
emotional jurassic park connection at
all it just feels really forced and
biggest disappointment of the year for
sure but i didn't have high expectations
so maybe it's just kind of expected at
this point but it did give me leave me
feeling like okay i'm done with the
jurassic films for a long long time like
we gotta move on this is not working
it's just not like they've run out of
ideas for it and it's showing and
they're just banking on people buying
toys and hoping they like these big
monsters fighting so that's your cup of
tea great but you're not getting
anything else with that so i'm giving
this one a 5.2 not all bad again because
you get some really good action here you
do get that what you're paying for in
that blockbuster aspect of it where you
get you know really cool dinosaurs here
and there but you gotta expect a lot of
bugs so get ready for the locust and
some clone child story lines so
be hype but yeah it's better than the
fallen kingdom that's all i'm gonna say
but i even like jurassic park three
better than this so that's what i have
to say about this film but
let me know if you plan on seeing it let
me know when you do see what your
thoughts are i really want to hear you
guys thoughts on this and please make
sure to subscribe to almost one of my
movie reviews i also do celebrity
interviews tv reviews as well please
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram tick tock for more of
me and i'll see you next time